Today's global snack comes from Cape Town.
With three and a half million residents, it's South Africa's second largest city after Johannesburg.
Edwin and Mervin Collins run a snack bar right in the center of town.
I'm grilling lamb and lovely jumbo boerewors rolls freshly flame-grilled today.
There's chicken or pork on offer, but the traditional item here...
...is a uniquely South African grilled sausage invented by the first European settlers.
It's called boerewors.
It has a distinct taste, like it's from the farm...
...because that's what it is, farm sausage boerewors.
"Boer" are farmers.
The sausage consists of 30 percent pork, twice as much beef and lots of fat,...
...but the distinct taste comes from the spices used to flavor the meat and the sauces.
We put five different spices.
Spices that you don't normally associate with boerewors...
...like coriander, cumin, vinegar, obviously salt, pepper and African dahlia too.